where were you on the radio so I wanted
to be Robin right oh stop so I go to
grad school in England right I leave
England I'm not done with my
dissertation but I'm totally broke and I
want to finish the dissertation so I can
move on with my life and move to New
York and you know work for the ACLU or
something and so we gotta get so I
decide that I have to be miserable
because if I'm not miserable I'll be too
happy hanging out where I'm doing not
writing this dissertation I don't write
so I have two choices for where I can
live and be super miserable so miserable
that I will finish my PhD in order to
leave in a men's prison the best friend
from the Air Force was a Republican
lawyer in Orange County California and I
thought that would make nice guy that
would make me miserable he offered me a
spare room like in his house or at a law
firm or something to go where I thought
okay I'd be miserable
that won't work that's one option the
other option is that I had friends who
had moved to Northampton Massachusetts
because they were there was a 2020 peace
saying that it was the lesbian capital
of America okay we'll go open up a
lesbian B&B right I thought that sounds
like the 17th circle of hell so they
moved to the country to New England in
this snowy part of the world to go open
up a B&B and after doing that for five
years they learned it was the 17th
circle of hell they shut it down and
they were just gonna be living in this
big house like raising dogs going back
to work full time and they said you'll
be miserable here but you can live here
without paying rent and finish your
dissertation I said great so I'm with
them right and I'm used to friends of
these kind of people who were good to
you back in the day yeah yeah you should
all have good friends yeah yeah so that
was that was nice and they listened to
this morning show they listened to the
local morning zoo radio show in Holyoke
massive in the morning and the news girl
on the Dave in the morning show was
Denis and Denyse left and they held open
on-air auditions for somebody to replace
Denis to be the Robin of the Dave in the
morning show and you went in and my
friends I'd never listened to the show
my friends dared me to do it because I
was doing odd jobs and I was bad at
everything right and I got hired on the
spot
Wow no kidding yeah was total schmuck
that's so unfair frigging contest
with those reservations hey I got maniac
trying to get into this thing so you
easily got into radio minimum-wage
morning showed sidekick were you a hit
at first we were a tertiary unranked
market operating out of a strip mall so
hard to tell all right so that was a
good entry-level job yeah and then do
get tapped for air America out of that
job I thought that that was just one of
my weird odd jobs I thought I did it for
a year and then I had to go back to
England to defend my dissertation did
you like doing the radio I loved it you
loved it but I thought its minimum wage
job that I have to get up at 3 in the
morning for like this isn't my future
this is but you became a little local
celebrity right a little bit no one
listened to the dump station I go to
parties go up on the radio really where
the radio it's in your car right yes so
you you did that you figured that's it
it's over yeah it's not gonna be
anything and then I went to go I quit so
that I could go defend my dissertation
in England right and that was a couple
of weeks before 9/11 I came back 9/11
happened and I had this great desire to
be back on the radio I thought that I
would never be on the radio again but I
really I mean every you remember what it
was like I mean even if you didn't live
in New York it was you know people
rushing to the VA Medical Center to
donate blood and we weren't playing
music on the radio stations anymore
people wanted a talk talking every show
every real ocol radio station that we
hadn't been turned over into voice
tracking became a call-in show because
people yeah wanted to talk about what's
going on and I realized I wanted to be
part of that I felt like I felt like I
could help I felt like it would be a way
- so where did you go whose that air
America so that was no that was another
local radio station in North Hampton a
great station W our side of the river
this is a which is a awesome music
station and they just let me pick up
shifts and that turned into me getting
the morning show and then I did that for
a year so and then air America got found
it and then I put in my I tried to cause
that huge disappointment in your life
here America not working out I mean it
was it was a great idea was like hey
let's start a liberal radio network yeah
but I thought they took on too much at
the very beginning you don't just start
a network well my thought always was on
that that the business plan is take
somebody who's great
who's liberal put them on the radio what
do you need a whole network
build around yeah I think that probably
would have worked better a little too
ambitious but the up you know the other
thing is would it have worked what even
if that even if that smarter business
model had been done would it have worked
anyway I mean AM radio is conservative
radio right I mean it's just they
haven't found great communicators do you
know you know to be number one in radio
I this I have theories on to be number
one in radio takes a unique ability
you're talking sometimes for 3-4 hours
at a time you've got to be compelling
for whatever reason and you're putting
on a show that primarily rests on you
you know and so you've got to really
take it to a level that's unheard of
there's very few people who can do it
but I believe if there was a person like
yourself who's intelligent who has a way
of broadcasting that engages people that
they could be even on a conservative
radio station and be the one lone voice
of the you know of liberalism why not
well you know I I don't think I was
great on the radio I mean I think that I
did a radio show that was very much like
my TV show now it was like a blizzard of
words but wasn't be explaining this big
long thing and when you talk on the
radio you draw people in and make people
feel like they could be sitting here
talking to you but why why why would why
wouldn't you work why didn't he work on
radio but you work on TV like why does
it work on TV because radio is a more I
mean this is gonna sound cheesy but
radio is a more intimate medium you're
talking right into somebody's ear on
television they're watching you on a
screen and so it's okay I think on TV if
you are sort of up on a podium
explaining some right
you're a better TV performer yeah and on
radio you got to be able to draw people
in in a really personal way and I don't
think that I loved radio and I would
love to go back to radio at some point
in my life but I don't think I'm I don't
I don't think I've think I've got a
better gene for TV than I had for radio
you
you